hello everyone and it is the uh game
you've all been waiting for it is round
three of the singfield cup and it is
Magnus Carlsen versus hunt smoke it just
speaks for itself Neiman uh it's a
beautiful game I'm not gonna spoil
anything because most of you probably
already know uh at the end result uh but
let's just enjoy the game uh because
there is so much to enjoy in this game
that uh I don't know I'm afraid the the
video might even be too long but I'm try
I will try to contain myself uh so let's
dive straight into it the Magnus has the
white pieces and he opens with D4 we
have Knight to F6 C for E6 Knight to C3
and Bishop the B4 Hans except and goes
for the nimzo Indian defense and now uh
you could treat the names of Indian in
many different ways we've discussed uh
Queen City we've discussed Queen to E3
Knight to F3 is possible F3 the cloth
variation uh the instant A3 so Bishop to
G5 these are all very popular moves but
Magnus goes for G3 so rare move but it
has been played on the top level yeah
carwana played it against Wesley so and
and kariakin also mamijaro played it
against karyakin so it's not uh uh uh
you know Unthinkable to try something
like this and it's also a very nice uh
uh attempt at a surprise uh against uh
someone who is definitely fighting uh
for uh for Glory and to reach 2700 as
you guys know Magnus is trying to reach
2 900 whereas Hans is uh trying to get
2700 for the first time and if he beats
Magnus here with the black pieces uh he
will reach that 2700 live rating so uh
here we have castles uh continuing in
the uh classical way these are all very
standard names of Indian moves the
bishop to G2 we have D5 and A3 now
checking if maybe Hans wants to go back
or does he want to capture on C3 hunts
captures this is the best way to do this
be characters and the now D captors on
C4 we have Knight with three by Magnus
and C5 again everything played to
absolute perfection we have castles Now
by Magnus and now there are some games
that reach this position but in none of
them see captures and D4 was played
which is a new move and in fact the top
move recommended by the engine so
in terms of surprising hunts it didn't
go all that well and it is now already
as of move nine that we have a
completely new game so okay Queen
captures on D4 Magnus offers a queen
trade and now you could go for the trade
for example Queen captures Knight
captures and then uh try something like
Knights the D5 you go after the C3 Pawn
sort of uh for force a trade here let's
say Bishop captures e counters and the
game continues but uh it's uh Hans feels
that he can do better he goes Knight to
C6 he wants to force a trade on d8 so he
gets a rook into the game right away but
this also means that Magnus can now
reclaim his spawn in the other variation
hunts we'll keep the extra Pawn but
Magnus would have uh all the usual uh
you know uh uh perks of of gambiting a
pawn here so here we have E5 and now
Bishop to G5 by Magnus spinning the
Knight we have H6 and now Rook F the D1
and here again Hans really has to figure
out how to go about this and the moving
the queen is not the way to go if you
move the queen let's say queen E7 then
Magnus can just trade already winning a
Tempo characters captures Knight the D2
now the Knight is coming to E4 and it
will be a great position for him so Hans
plays the best move possible and that is
Bishop to E6 he offers a queen trade and
this is now a queen trade Magnus cannot
decline as his Bishop is hanging and
also the queen is hanging so here Rook
captures on d8 we have Bishop captures
on c for Rook captures an A8 Rook
captures and now Bishop captures and F6
ruining Hans spawn structure captures
captures and now as the E2 Pawn is
hanging King to F1
uh and now uh if you if you count the
pawns a Magnus has six pawns and Hans
has six pawns however uh Magnus has uh
three Pawn islands and Hans also has
three point Islands but the dh6 pawn
it's very hard to reach whereas the C3
and A3 pawns are a bit easier to reach
and it's very easy to organize and
attack against the the the the C Pawn so
here we have rooked rooked the d8 and
this is the way to go if you go Rook the
C8 you want to go after the pawn right
away then magnets can play Knight to D2
uh attack the bishop he wants the bishop
move start pushing the pawn so this way
Rook the d8 prevents Knight to D2 and
now Magnus plays King E1 Knight to A5
now uh and a rook to D1 offering a rook
trade and only now Rook the C8 now
piling up on the on the C3 Pawn so
Knight D2 chasing away the bishop and
the bishop to E6 and now uh there is
really no good way to defend um the C3
Pawn if you try something like Rook to
C1 uh it uh it doesn't really do all
that much you can never push the pawn to
see for its uh defended three times and
it's just a very very passive position
for Magnus so instead Magnus goes for C4
he offers this pawn and then he will get
some control play he will get something
like Rook to d8 he might go after the
queen side pawns he might organize an
attack against the F7 Pawn uh this is
definitely the way to go so Bishop
captures and C4 Hans grabs the pawn
Knight captures Rook captures and now
Rook to d8 with check King G7 and now
Bishop to D5 attacking the rook and also
putting pressure on F7 so if Magnus can
get rooked to D7 and he would win back
his pawn and probably get a better
position so Rook to C7 this is a move
you have to play and now Rook to A8
going after the A7 pawn and Here pawn
just spawned A6 by Hans the situation on
the clock is 29 minutes for Magnus and
49 minutes for Han so it's not like
Magnus surprised hunts and now Hans is
burning time it's actually Magnus who
tried to surprise Hans and didn't
surprise him and now it's Magnus who is
burning time trying to get back into the
game so Rook the B8 and now we have
pawned the F5 and this is another top
top move by Hans um my problem is if you
go if you go B5 then again Rook 8 puts
pressure on A6 and you've just created a
weakness so F5 is the way to go yeah
especially because you want to play Rook
to C5 if you don't play F5 you play Just
Rook the C5 then E4 is very strong F5
prevents uh the pawn from being pushed
to E4 so F5 we have Rook to E8 Now by
Magnus going after the E5 pawn and now
uh just Pawn to E4 and here it's uh
definitely a a good question how can
Magnus continue playing this there is
nothing to attack there's nothing to put
pressure to uh it's best to just uh sit
and sit and wait and but that also means
that hunts will be able to just start
improving the position of his King
especially if the Rook moves then even
King E5 and so on uh so Magnus plays G4
and now it kinda does look like he wants
the a breakout of those pawns and then
pick up the E4 Pawn but it doesn't work
Hans will simply uh pick up Hans will
simply undouble his pawns and here he
goes Rook to C5 this is the way to go
the bishop is attacked and the now
Magnus goes back Bishop to A2 it's a
question whether to just play like this
or to go Rook to d8 but if you move the
Rook then the king just starts marching
into into the game so Bishop to A2 and
now Hans played Knight the C4 now for
those of you who are interested I've
seen some of you were interested in the
previous video where where I've shown a
very very long assess a super computer
line
that as the position kind of is winning
for Hans here but it's uh I mean it's I
I will show it after I I show you the
game because it's too complicated and
it's uh it's like science fiction of
course nobody would expect anyone to
play this uh so okay Knight the C4 by
Hans uh and now comes uh Pawn to A4 as
the A3 Pawn was attacked you could also
consider just trading here Bishop
cappers through captors and then G
captures on F5 this is this possible but
hunts will always be better here and the
Magnus will just have to fight for the
draw attacks the A3 Pawn for example
Rook to B8 B5 now defending the pawn and
after Rook the B6 Rook captures on A3
and this is I mean it looks very ugly
even if you can save this uh it's a two
connected past pawns on the queen side
uh definitely not something you you want
you want to face so instead after Knight
the C4 we have A4 just defending the
point on like this and now comes Knight
to D6 and here Magnus goes Rook to E7
The Rook is attacked and if you go Rook
to d8 uh it would be it would be a
fiasco if Magnus played Rook to d8 then
Hans has this beautiful E3 move uh and
it resigns for for Magnus problem is if
you capture the Knight and there's the
spectacular Rook to C1 with check and
now there is no move as the king cannot
go up the board so look the D1 has to be
played and now just captures captures
and E captures on F2 and you get a queen
next move uh the king cannot go to E1
and it doesn't matter even if after E3
you don't capture the Knight it's gonna
be just a winning end game for for Hans
because if you capture an E3 then Knight
D4 you've freed up this square there's
no kicking away tonight these two
squares are covered and now after King
to F1
uh Rook the C1 check King to G2 now Rook
the C2 attacks the bishop attacks the E2
pawn and after Bishop to D5 you just
trade Rook captures an E2 check King to
F1 Rook the F2 would check King to E1 uh
seems like a bad idea because uh well it
seems like the Knight can be captured
and then the Rook will hang with just
root captures an H2 and uh after it's a
bishop captures on B7 Knight C5 now
attacks the bishop defends the pawn
bishop back to F3 there's F characters
and G4 Bishop captures and now Rook to
A2 going after the pawn there's no
defending this pawn bishop D1 Knight
captures an A4 and hunts would be up two
Pawns in a in a winning end game so
that's the problem if Magnus goes Rook
to d8 so here Rook the E7 by Magnus and
the now hunts Place F captors and G4 and
now the position is so so complicated uh
that there are other moves that you of
course can play and I will show you one
such idea and that is Rook to C2 you
first put pressure on the on the bishop
and it doesn't matter where the bishop
moves in Bishop B3 you attack it again
and if the bishop moves back now you
play F characters on G4 but now it's a
little bit different with the The Rook
being on C3 for example if Rook D7 goes
after the Knight you just play Knight C4
and how are you stopping uh all of the
all of the threats here for example if
Bishop captures and C4 uh Rook C1 check
King V2 Rook campus and C4 and after
Rook captures on B7 just Rook capture
Sun A4 again leaves you uh with a two
point Advantage you can just push the
king push F5 H5 H4 and it's uh it's just
game over also you have a past a pawn so
Rook C2 might be a little Improvement
but okay if captures on G4 also works
and did not Magnus plays Rook to D7 and
this uh uh pretty much gives us the same
position as the one that we've discussed
but not exactly the same here Hans does
find E3 he pushes it and now Magnus of
course knows that capturing the Knight
is impossible because of Rook to C1
check we've already shown that line so F
captures an E3 and now Knight to E4 and
here we have King to F1 by Magnus the
problem is even if you capture on F7 it
doesn't do all that much it's it will
only get in your way through captures
King G6 and now King F1 because of
course you don't want to get checkmated
the Knight covers D2 and F2 so King to
F1 rooked the C1 with Chuck King G2 and
now Rook C2 like in the other line
attacking the bishop and the E2 pawn
bishop D5 Rook campus I need to King G1
and now Knight the C3
attacking the bishop and there's uh it
really doesn't matter what you do here
if Bishop to B3 defending the A4 Pawn
you just go B5 and for example captures
captures if Rook D7 just H5 and you
slowly slowly push and uh win the game
so that's that's how you do it uh so
Magnus uh decides to go for King to F1
and now Magnus is down to eight minutes
and the clock Hans has 20 minutes on the
clock and there are still six more moves
that we made for time control to be
reached and here we have Rook to C1 with
check and here uh uh you could also try
Rook the F5 with check it so it's a very
nice line but Hans decided for Rook to
C1 the the difference is here after King
the G2 you play B5 of course you save
your pawn and after captors captures and
rookie 7 going after the knight uh
there's Knight the C3 now again
attacking the bishop and the pawn here
and once the bishop move you just
capture it and now it's a bit uh safer
with with the rook and on the f file not
only are you guarding in the F7 Pawn but
also you are cutting the king off from
going uh to the center of the board but
Hans uh deems it unnecessary he plays
Rook the C1 check we have King to G2 and
now he just goes Rook the C2 he doesn't
care about the F7 pawn and okay Magnus
plays Bishop captures on F7 now comes
Rook captures on E2 with check King G1
and now Rook to E1 with check King G2
Rook to E2 with check King G1 and now
King the F6 getting out of um uh out of
this nasty Discovery square and now
Bishop to D5 by Magnus attacking the
Knight and here situation on the clock
is five minutes for Magnus 10 minutes
for Hans uh Magnus plays or rather hunts
plays a rook to D2 and it's it's
definitely the way to go of course now
the Knight cannot be captured because
the Rook Kings so Magnus just goes Rook
F7 check King G6 and now uh it seems
like uh uh Magnus can play Rook to D7
because it sets up a discovery the king
is now on a light square and then Bishop
to F7 check would mean mean that maybe
you can win The Rook the problem is you
have to play Rook D7 here Rook D7 here
and it's uh well Hans would still push
but probably Magnus can draw this you
either trade here with characters
captures or you don't if you play
Knights the G5 there's Bishop to G2 and
you can never reach the H2 Pawn even if
this check you don't have access to the
to the H2 Pawn this is all very
complicated stuff with little time on
the clock so Magnus played Rook to D7
and now uh Hans finds a brilliancy and
that is Knight to G5 a move that should
not be possible as like we've said
Bishop F7 check picks up the Rook but
that's just the thing no it doesn't
I will just show you what happens if you
don't play Bishop to F7 let's say Magnus
tries King F1 for some reason uh there's
Knight F3 always and then after Bishop e
for check King to H5 The Rook is always
defended so you don't have to worry
about that any throw characters on B7
You're Gonna Play Knight captures on H2
with Chuck King G1 now King H4 and this
is of course not winning for uh for for
Hans if Rook to B1 you're just gonna
play King to G3 and there's no winning
uh saving this Knight to F3 check is
coming and that's it so Magnus has to go
for it he plays Bishop to F7 check but
now just King to F5 and also uh King to
F6 makes a bit more sense as it keeps
attacking the bishop but Hans shows that
he uh can uh play it any way he wants
and that the position is still winning
for him now the problem is if Magnus
grabs The Rook it just Knights the F3
with Chuck King G2 and not Knight
captures on D2 again leaves hunt with a
winning position uh which is uh which is
kind of what happened in the game so
here Magnus plays A5 uh sort of the idea
why maybe King to F6 is a bit more
precise it would keep attacking
Carlson's Bishop so Magnus would not
have this A5 move uh to paralyze hans's
Queen side as now Magnus can paralyze
two pawns with his one Pawn but still
the pawn is on a dark Square Magnus has
a light Square Bishop it's gonna be very
easy for Hans to gobble it up so King
the E5 and this is the only move that
wins if you allow Bishop D5 to go after
B7 after A6 then Magnus is back in the
game so King E5 only move King to G3 and
not Knight the F1 with check
uh saying okay if you capture on G4 I'm
just going to capture on H2 with check
we can even show it captures captures
King H5 Knight F1 and now after King
captures just Knight captures on E3 and
like we said the pawn is on a dark
Square the bishop cannot reach the V7
Pawn it's gonna be very easy to just
gobble up this uh this Pawn no no no
problems there so after Knight F1 uh a
check we have King to F2 by Magnus now
comes Knight captures on H2 and the
Magnus here is seemingly without the
move but he finds one he finds E4 which
is very nice uh you are saying I'm
playing Bishop to D5 on the next move
and I'm going after the queen side pawns
and if you capture this then I have
Bishop to E6 the the king and E5 also
prevented Bishop to E6 as this is also
the way to go after the pawn so the pawn
kind of has to be captured so King
captures now comes Bishop to E6 and now
King to F4 we have Bishop the C8 Magnus
will now gobble up the queen side pawns
but the problem is Knight to F3 hunts
calculates precisely that he will be
able to grab the A5 Pawn before the A5
Pawn touches the light Square so Bishop
captures on B7 and now Knight the
knights the E5 and this is crucial if
you push G3 it's just a draw King G2 and
there's no more way for you to actually
uh win this for example Knight E2 Bishop
captures an A6 and this will now be a
draw if you go Knight to the B3 just
Bishop to B7 Knight captures here okay
it's perfectly fine but there's Bishop
D5 and the Knight is now paralyzed
that's the uh that's the problem so now
the king will have to go after the
bishop but then you have all the time in
the world to give up your Bishop for the
two pawns and this would be a draw so it
would be a very fun draw and a smart
draw but hunts says Nope Knight to E5 uh
Bishop captures an A6 knock ones Knight
the C6 the pawn is still on the dark
Square the bishop is blocking it so Hans
is winning this pawn bishop B7 Knight
captures an A5 Bishop to D5 Magnus traps
the Knight uh but it doesn't matter Pawn
to H5 and now if you just waste the move
King G5 uh of course King E5 kicks away
the bishop and then the Knight can come
back into the game so uh Bishop back to
F7 goes after the pawn uh H4 and now
Bishop to D5 and it was in this position
after playing Bishop to D5 uh is uh that
Magnus Carlsen resigned the game without
even waiting for a response from Hans uh
as there really is nothing more to be
done here so we've covered quite a few
lines and for those of you uh who are
maybe new to chess might be interested
in how do you actually win this uh you
well of course you just push pawns but
there are still some things you have to
be uh considerate of for example King E5
we first have to kick away the bishop to
get our Knight into the game Bishop G2
and now of course we activate the Knight
let's say Knight B3 King E3 now you just
bring the Knight very close to the to
the Past pawns King F2 King F4 now we
have King to G1 and Knight to F3 with
check of course if white trades then
it's completely winning so King F2 H3
Bishop to H1 and now G3 with check King
F1 and now not G2 I know most of you
know this but if you play G2 check you
do win the bishop but also you lose all
of your pawns and now it's a draw by
insufficient material so after King F1
you would have to go King E3 you would
have to spend a few more moves and now a
beautiful beautiful two Swang there is
no move white can make the King has no
squares the bishop cannot move uh and
that's pretty much it you you could try
being smart with someone like Bishop G2
but it's still fine you can just capture
and it seems like you can almost grab it
but not really King F4 King F1 King G4
now you wanna get your king all the way
there King G2 and now Knight the H2 we
have King G1 King the F3 and now King
the H1 again uh trying to trying to do
something but Knight to F1 King G1
Knight E3 King to H1 and now finally G2
with check this is how you do it King G1
King to E2 now King H2 and King F2 and
finally you control the G1 square and
that's it King H3 G1 queen king H4 and
queen G4 Checkmate uh so of course this
is all uh very very Elementary stuff and
I know all of you know this but in case
some of you were wondering that's how
you win this end game so really really
remarkable or remarkable stuff by uh
Hans Niemann this also means that Magnus
is uh well a few steps behind from
reaching his goal of of hitting that
2900 classical rating but Hans hits 2700
for the first time in his life here you
can have uh these are the uh the only
players that are above 2700 in the world
as of yesterday uh so only 42 players
and you can see in number 40 uh Hans
Neiman with 2702 0.3 which is uh which
is incredible especially uh if if you've
hit 2700 by beating Magnus Carlson uh
you know that uh well the 2700 is
definitely definitely not your plateau
and he joins the other youngsters so you
can see that Eric AC is in number 22
goukash number 24 uh there uh also Abdul
Sato broke into number 30 there's Doc in
number 35. so the youngsters are
definitely overtaking the the standings
and it's uh
okay it's uh it's questionable how the
the world's top uh 2700 list would look
like if for example there was no covet
if if you know the the players didn't
lose like a year year and a half two
years of playing actual classical events
yeah I think the uh the world's top list
will look much much different in that uh
younger players would be uh it would be
having a saying this definitely and also
uh here are the standings after round
three so Hans Neiman takes the lead by
beating Magnus Carlsen he's now in Sol
lead with two and a half points followed
by Wesley so with two points uh followed
by Magnus cross and Yani polish a few
job with one and a half and maximum and
linear Dominguez with one and a half and
with one point still 11 arunian Fabiano
Corona and Shakira mamajarov so a really
really awesome stuff here and also this
means that uh Magnus is uh undefeated
streak has also been broken Magnus has
started in another 3 this was his uh
53rd game or rather Magnus already
played 53 games without losing in
classical chess but the one that he
played today or rather yesterday the
54th one against Hans mochanimon was a
loss so now the the streak has been
broken and also uh Taurus Vincent uh
posted on Twitter that this is uh
Carlson's first loss to a below 2700
player with the black with the black
pieces in seven years uh I think uh the
the the last one that defeated Magnus
with black was Anish giri before B you
know before he actually hit uh 2700 So
This is a quite quite an astonishing
achievement uh so yeah that's the game I
hope you guys enjoyed it really really
wild stuff sorry it took a bit longer
but I mean some of those lines were so
crazy that
um I mean covering uh I mean covering
them was definitely not an easy task and
now for those of you who are interested
in the crazy super computer line that
I've mentioned just gonna briefly go
over it here after Bishop day two hunts
where he played Knights the C for f
characters and G4 is the immediate
winning line according to sese uh the
reason Hans didn't do this is of course
now Rook captures an E4 is possible but
it doesn't matter The Rook captures an
E4 Pawn to F5 now Rook to E3 as you will
have to defend your A3 Pawn at some
point now comes King F6 now the black
king becomes Super Active Pawn to F4
otherwise F4 is coming so Pawn to F4 uh
Knight the C for now attacking The Rook
uh Rook back to B8 and now Pawn to B5 we
have rooked the h8 going after the H6
Pawn now King G6 defending Rook the G8
check King the H5 Rook to A8 going after
the A6 Pawn now Rook the C6 just nicely
defending and after Rook f8 going after
this Pawn King to G6 now of course you
can try checking again King H7 Rook to
d8 now and now comes Pawn to H5 with
Bishop to B1 putting pressure on this
Pawn now Knight to D6 this is how you
defend it and after King to F2 Pawn to
H4 look at those pawns just marching
forward Rook 8 as there's really nothing
to to attack and now King G7 King to G2
now comes Knight to E4 uh Pawn to H3 and
now G3 with Bishop to D3 and now Knight
to C3 uh King to F3 and now Knight the
D5 and here after Rook to A7 check King
to F6 Rook to A8 and now Rook the C1
Rook captures any and this Rook to C1 is
actually the uh brilliancy that you
would have to see in order to even go
for this because now you have to spot a
double Pawn sacrifice in order to win
this uh which is kind of hard as this is
move 48 and you would have to see it on
move 29 in order to go for this uh Rook
to C1 giving up the A6 Pawn with check
Rook characters and A6 check King E7 and
now even Bishop captures an F5 but now
it doesn't really matter Rook to F1 with
check and that's the the winning idea uh
point is if you go King to G2 then it's
Knight to E3 Checkmate I know it's
disgusting it's disgusting to even look
at this uh so of course uh the king
cannot go to G2 unfortunately for the
white king so you have to go King E4
attack the Knight and now you even give
up the Knight G2 and you get a queen so
that's basically it and if King G6
trying to of course prevent this uh
Knight F6 check now the Knight will no
longer fall and after King to E5 now you
just play G1 Queen and that's it real
cast the capture real captors and now
you are up a full Rook so I mean okay I
only I've only shown this for for those
of you who are interested in such lines
but uh
um and usually we don't have access to
them since a uh the Norwegian
supercomputer is only operational when
Magnus is playing so for other uh for
the games that Magnus is not playing we
do not have insight into such uh such
you know uh sorcery
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh big congratulations to
Hans on beating the world champion this
way truly truly amazing stuff uh I would
like to thank Gerald Watts Uh Wood
thanks Paul certanwich and the blitz44
chess for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the uh of
this uh wonderful event the singfield
cup until it finishes so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day